Light makes right. I love this little play on words that Andrew Glassner made
up back in the 1980s. It succinctly captures a kernel of truth about computer
graphics. The more you can determine about how light moves through an
environment, the better your results will be. I've talked a bit before about
light, and how it bounces around a scene, eventually reaching the eye. The idea
is that each light, often called an emitter, sends photons out. The fate of
each photon is that it's absorbed as is, or reflected. An object can absorb
light and in fact, almost everything absorbs at least a little light. Not even
the highest quality mirror reflects 100% of the light hitting it. The numbers
are usually more in the 90 to 95% range. Along the way photons can be absorbed
by dust, water droplet's, or other particles in the air. Or the inside of
translucent objects themselves. This simple photon model ignores various
effects such as polarization and fluorescence. But that's generally fine in
indirective computer graphics. Things are complex enough. We can see objects
precisely because photons ultimately travel from them to us. The reason objects
have different colors is that each varies in how much it reflects various
wavelengths of light. Where we do have some choice in computer graphics is what
light paths we follow. The two paths we've used so far are light to surface and
surface to eye. We've been a bit more elaborate with surface to eye in that
we've allowed transparent filters along this path to modify the color.